dear colleagues
we deeply regret the decision of the
russian federation to veto the
resolution
the council lost a precious opportunity
to show to the world its unity
its power
its usefulness us correspondent mark
stone is listening in uh mark tell us
what's happening
well it may seem insignificant given uh
what we have just been witnessing but it
is not uh insignificant the results of
this un security council resolution is
11
of the 15 votes voting in favor of the
resolution
one against obviously russia but three
abstentions china india and the united
arab emirates now this is significant uh
china was expected to vote with russia
against the resolution they are of
course close allies they are
geographical neighbours uh president
putin likes to see himself as very close
to russian premier xi jinping and so the
fact that over the course of some very
very difficult negotiations in the um in
the past 24 hours inside that chamber uh
western diplomats have as they put it
managed to peel china away from russia
and
persuade china to abstain on that vote
rather than vote against it there was
never any expectation that china would
vote with the west but an abstention
is very important indeed and it seems as
though well it is clear now that india
and the united arab emirates both with
close ties and concerns about upsetting
the russians have also decided to
abstain there was some concern that they
would vote against as well so what this
does is it sends a very very clear
message from the top diplomatic uh body
of the world uh to isolate russia and to
cement that isolation i think we will
probably hear some more speeches i don't
know whether we can listen back in to
what people are saying
today in an effort to protect russia's
premeditated unprovoked
unjustified and unconscionable war in
ukraine
but let me make one thing clear
russia
you cannot veto this resolution you can
veto this resolution but you cannot veto
our voices you cannot
veto the truth
you cannot
veto our principles you cannot veto
the ukrainian people
you cannot veto
the u.n charter
and you will not
veto
accountability
responsible members of this security
council have stood together today in the
face of russia's aggression
and we will continue to
stand with ukraine
supporting it in every way we can
we are united behind ukraine and its
people
despite a reckless irresponsible
permanent member of the security council
abusing its power to attack its neighbor
and subvert the u.n and our
international system
this vote showed which countries truly
believe in supporting the core
principles of the un
and which ones deploy them as convenient
catchphrases
this vote showed which security council
members support the u.n charter
and which ones do not
we will be addressing this matter in the
general assembly
where the russian veto does not apply
and the nations of the world
can will
and should hold russia accountable and
stand in solidarity with ukraine
before i conclude i want to commend
the true
and tremendous courage we are seeing
from the ukrainian people i want to
thank the ukrainian permanent
representative who is here with us today
earlier today president biden spoke with
president zielinski and personally
commended the brave actions of the
ukrainian people who are fighting to
defend their country
he also conveyed ongoing economic
humanitarian and security support being
provided by the united states as well as
our continued effort
to rally other countries to provide
similar assistance
it's hard to imagine what it must feel
like to see tanks rolling into your city
to see bombs
dropped
on your streets
to see soldiers
storm your parks
and your gardens
but in the face of all of this
everyday ukrainian people
are taking extraordinary actions
to protect their children to protect
their country to defend everything they
hold dear
i also want to commend the courage of
the thousands of people in russia who
are protesting putin's war
despite grave risk to their personal
safety
they will keep chanting no war
they will keep asking how many russian
lives
putin wants to sacrifice for his cynical
ambitions
as we move forward
i hope more member states take their
cues
from this courage
and honor all of this bravery
with more of our own thank you